A LOT OF PEOPLE MAY NOT
REMEMBER NEW YEAR'S EVE,
SINCE DISCOUNT CHAMPAGNE
AND 2016 RAGE DON'T MIX,
BUT STUFF HAPPENED!
JENNY MCCARTHY WAS COLD!
PEOPLE IN TIMES SQUARE
DIDN'T PEE FOR, LIKE, 12 HOURS.
AND MARIAH CAREY PERFORMED, OR,
RATHER, WANDERED AROUND ONSTAGE
MUMBLING INSTEAD OF LIP-SYNCING
BECAUSE OF TECHNICAL ISSUES
AND SO FORTH.
I'LL JUST GET
THROUGH THE MOMENT, OKAY?
♪ I FEEL...
♪ I FEEL... ♪
AND...
♪
(RECORDING OF CAREY
SINGING HIGH NOTES PLAYING)
I WANT A HOLIDAY, TOO.
♪ BABY, BABY, WE BELONG
TOGETHER, BABY ♪
♪ WHEN YOU LEFT
I LOST A PART OF ME... ♪
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
HAPPY NEW YEAR.
-(APPLAUSE AND CHEERING)
-STILL THE BEST!
YES.
AM I HIGH, OR WAS THAT FLAWLESS?
-(LAUGHTER)
-HARDWICK: THAT WAS...
100 POINTS TO DOUG FOR THAT.
-(LAUGHTER)
-NO ONE HAS
EVER BEEN AS DEDICATED TO A JOB
AS THOSE BACKUP DANCERS.
-YEAH.
-(LAUGHTER)
YOU CAN ALMOST HEAR 'EM
WITH THE FEATHERS GOING,
-"KEEP IT TOGETHER, KEVIN."
-YEAH.
"THIS IS WHY YOU WENT
TO JUILLIARD!"
I THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
JUST CUT AWAY
AND-AND LET
THIS LAWN MOWER FILL IN.
♪ YOU MAKE ME FEEL SO HIGH...
-YES! YES! YES!
-YES!
-OH, YEAH!
-(APPLAUSE)
(IMITATES WOMAN): I'LL HAVE
WHAT THE LAWN MOWER'S HAVING.
-(LAUGHTER)
-UH, AFTER MARIAH'S LIVE,
NATIONALLY TELEVISED DEBACLE,
ME WITHOUT THE DICK JOKES,
RYAN SEACREST,
HANDLED IT FLAWLESSLY.
NO MATTER WHAT MARIAH DOES,
THE CROWD ABSOLUTELY LOVES IT.
YOU CAN'T GO WRONG
WITH MS. CAREY,
AND THOSE HITS,
THOSE SONGS EVERYBODY KNOWS...
AND HOW ABOUT THOSE LYRICS
THAT EVERYONE KNOWS,
-EXCEPT FOR MARIAH CAREY.
-(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
BUT...
THAT IS...
THAT IS SOME NEXT-LEVEL, EXPERT-
LEVEL DAMAGE CONTROL ON THE FLY.
SO, COMEDIANS,
HOW ELSE COULD RYAN SEACREST
HAVE GIVEN HER PERFORMANCE
A POSITIVE SPIN?
-JONAH RAY.
-YOU GOTTA HAND IT TO MARIAH.
SHE'S PROBABLY NOT A RACIST.
(LAUGHTER)
POINTS.
-DOUG. -SHE COULD SHOOT SOMEBODY
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE STREET,
AND EVERYONE
WOULD STILL VOTE FOR HER.
-(LAUGHTER)
-YEAH. POINTS. LAURIE.
SHE STILL HAS BOTH HER BOOBS.
-HARDWICK: YAY!
-(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)